questa è la storia di un raggio di sole
caduto dal cielo sul nostro pianeta
leggera atterrò su un mazzo di viole e
poi volo via soletto senza meta
e mentre silente in un villaggio vagava
incontra una gazza ladra che lo vide
arrivare da dove viene il chiese la
brava rispose lui scosso to2 rubare
quindi con me gli fece con un sussulto
tu sei così bello e con te voglio stare
ti prego non prenderlo come un insulto
ma sono di corsa e ho altro da fare
mi piace la furba volavano metano tristi
si chiedeva quale fosse il suo destino
come del suo scopo si chiedeva invano
finché non incontra un essere piccolino
erano gli disse che luci favolose tu
porti la gioia ti prego rimani come il
raggio di sole vanitoso rispose scusami
tanto ma vuoi essere siete troppo strani
distante altezzoso tutti quanti lo
ammiravano dalla giraffa al cammello
persino il tricheco si curano ormai di
aver trovato un piano fin quando per
strada
incontrò un uomo cieco e i fermati tu
che mi passi vicino
l'uomo si contò chiedendo che fosse
perché non mi hamelin è anche un pochino
perché sono cieco fece l'uomo dalle
scarpe rosse aspetta però lasciati il
volto toccare non aver paura aggiunse
sottovoce fa su un fatto di luce luce
solare per te non esiste una cosa trovò
c'e stanchi avvicinato 6 rimase colpito
è vero ha ragione gli disse di cuore per
una cosa io ho sentito e della dolcezza
del tuo calore
nessuno tra questa cosa il raggio
pensava forse lane luce aveva messo un
velo e questa domanda giorno e notte lo
assillava finché non arrivò in un paese
di gelo da una finestra vita ha letto
una bambina bianca ma che la sinistra
silenziosa e dopo essere entrato
nascosto dietro una tendina la bim apri
gli occhi di colpa ansiosa ho fatto
disse se stessa
un sogno strano un angelo del cielo mi
prendeva per la mano
così dal nulla e jair appariva ed ennio
brutto male per i magi amico arriva e
quella sera stessa il raggio capi la
morale lento e fermo
guardo alla piccola respirare e dopo
averle dato in fronte un bacino spari
come d'incanto è l'arma del mattino e
questa storia ha forse ci spinge a
ricordare ognuno nel suo piccolo
qualcosa può donare e mentre
continueranno a seguirsi tante mattine
io metto a questa storia la parola fine